what up friends this is day I don't know
three of the Vlog that I've been trying
to get done what
um and today we are gonna be in downtown
Summerlin
um picking up an early birthday present
for me and uh iPad for taika because he
broke his last one and I was gonna get
it fixed but it's just so old they're
like honestly it'd be cheaper to just
get a new one we're like
all right not that he needed he hasn't
had one in like about a month but we're
gonna do some traveling so I do want to
have some sort of side entertainment for
those moments where he needs to be a
little bit more
um
I don't know where he's just gonna have
to be sitting for longer periods of time
um and
what else I don't know I think we're
just gonna explore and be really super
CUNY I do want to know that today is a
Wednesday and this is so rare for us
it's super cutie to get out here get
some skin on our faces and bodies
and papa is back
okay make sure he's holding on okay
these [ __ ]
and I do have a pimple patch here just
in case you're wondering you're probably
not well I get it this is what I loved
about unplanned trips is I have no
agenda so when things pop up I'm like oh
actually can I so first stop is West Elm
because as you guys know we're moving so
why not look at some potential Furniture
you know thank you cancer
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] he's inside
oh I know that guy
hey
cutie patootie
okay monkey where'd you see that was
funny
this yeah
oh that is funny and the dog is wearing
hair what he's wearing which one's Papa
which one's taika
um
how could you do that to me how could
you do that to me
okay another news I saw some chairs that
actually really like check these out
look at this it's really pretty it's
this like mesh material
the wood feels nice they're not very
heavy I do like a heavier
chair but I mean this is nice
I like it
not buying anything but it's really
pretty next stop
karate and Barrel
no let's go in because it's gonna be a
jerk no
excuse me
stop
so the case for free this is look at
this chair it's so cool
look at all these like CUNY little
neutral colors and I like that it has
like this weird Japanese traditional
Japanese shoe split down the middle I
think that's so cool and I like this
table
because I really do like this random
gold accent
oh it's because it's a gold bar there
that's pretty wow I do like it
very cool
so now it's time for me to look for my
birthday present at how do you pronounce
this
so the table Sur La Table
I don't know but they they sell a lot of
cooking everything learn
laugh laugh
yeah this one's way better than what's
permanently on your arm so I've been
really getting into cooking desserts
specifically so I told papa for my
birthday I want to get a mixer
so we're gonna get a mixer because I
really really really really really love
getting into like baking and I've been
doing it for like a few months now like
Non-Stop
so excited
this makes it easy for me so I don't
have to guess what Mom bear's birthday
present is or what she wants so I'm like
yes not only do I get exactly what she
wants the results of the mixer mix me
but
a happy happy fat boy look at those
handles
oh the roller handles
this store is so freaking cool it has
everything you can think of for baking
and cooking
and here we are
and I was telling Papa I'm like oh my
God I don't want to spend 500 bucks on
just something that I'm barely getting
into but I am super excited for it but
I'm like let me do my research it this
is this is a pretty a pretty big price
tag where I'm like wait a minute
let me do research and let me see if I
even need it because right now I'm such
a newbie
I don't want to invest so much money and
then I'm like yeah I mean you know what
I
mean
let's just hold up a little bit what's
going on what the only way to learn is
to try though yeah but I'd rather try
with like I don't know
it's a pizza Smart Oven
that's so smart I guess you put in the
type of Pizza in crispy New York
whatever and look a little super cool I
don't know what's going on over there
he's just been acting
why are you over there
he's been not listening I don't even
know why he put himself in a corner I
don't like that why so he's upset
because he wants to get a Build-A-Bear
yep but in this family yeah yeah I think
but in this family
we gotta earn things right that's
something we always teach and I was like
oh what did you do to earn it because he
knows what the goal is he gets five
Spider-Man which means his teacher tells
him he did a good job every single day
to catch you up he's been on bad
behavior so we've been pulled in so that
we can supervise and and fix this course
this bad horse that type is going down
so the teacher is going okay sounds
familiar right it sounds like kind of
Bart's childhood
but she's going okay so every day I'm
gonna check in with taika and I'm gonna
report back to you guys if he gets three
Spider-Mans he had a good day and she
breaks down into categories that's the
Spider-Man that Papa's talking about
yeah and so uh since he heard that and
obviously that's the news that kids
don't want to hear he's been kind of
doing a little fit here and there yeah
and he put himself in the corner get
over here dude
parenting ain't for the week you know
what I'm saying
[Applause]
taika's iPad has been acquired here we
go
we ended up getting a super basic ninth
generation model but we specifically
added what is it called
memory memory uh the care Apple Care to
it how ironic you can't remember memory
no it was not memory it's AppleCare yes
because I was gonna say insurance but we
added memory too we're fine we added
memory so I for sure got AppleCare
because it's good for like minimum two
years you're paying 69 for both of those
years they'll replace it when it gets
shattered so I should have got it the
first
iPad and I don't know why I did it maybe
because I thought it was mine and I'm
like nothing's gonna happen to it and
here we are but that was a sixth
generation so this one is a ninth
generation that's how old Tiger's iPad
was so it was about time that we got it
okay so now we're about to eat dinner
and papa came up with a really cool game
perfect iPad has been acquired we had a
CUNY little walk through downtown
Summerlin now we are at via Brazil
because this guy's been
still dieting but Loosely right show me
the the hand movement you did when I'm
asked if you're
going to ask you if you're that's not
what you did oh but I was like are you
guiding and you went like you shook your
hand
yeah that's what he did so he's been
craving some meaty meat meats you know
what I ate for lunch the same thing I
eat instead of chicken you ate me no the
same thing as you I shredded chicken
breast tricking that's it
yeah he had dinner you had dinner ready
well he had a late lunch
no milkshake so yeah let's check what
this place is all about
yes please can you grab it for me baby
oh look at that
[Applause]
thank you
so good
right here I have uh my favorite piece
of meat at these Brazilian steakhouses
it's called pecania and they usually
marinate in like a garlic olive oil
thing and all my if you can't even do
this at home I don't know
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God check out all these sides
what is that watermelon salad okay
eggplant steak
what
what is this
fried rice
alfredo pasta
these meatballs
so this is what I ended up with fried
rice
uh uh what is this called
some beans with meat and white rice and
some veggie Tables
collard greens
the cheese bread what is that oh sauteed
mushrooms and Masha potatoes what a
spread it's a really good spread
wow this is just happiness
monkey tell me what is going on right
now I'm lucky I'm lucky look at that
look look how much ice cream yeah where
did Papa take you just now McDonald's
yes
to get what dude
the biggest ice cream and what else did
Papa get
nothing nothing we just got a phone no
he just got ice cream just for you
because he loves you so much look at
that ice cream right behind this right
right behind Papa I'm okay thank you you
sure it looks delicious that's
you went a little naughty oh that is he
did this with this diet so I mean he's
doing that like a little good a little
bad a little good a little bit yeah like
I didn't eat any carbs during dinner you
don't try to compensate for that so
trying to get a little bit of flavors in
my mouth
while still trying to you know mitigate
the calories here and there even that
does look delicious this dude is happy
happy I mean if you're gonna get any ice
cream it should be McDonald's because I
don't even think they use Dairy so the
fat is really low
I thought I remember that good to know
cutie
enjoy dude